now more than a quarter of women say
they have never asked for a pay rise
that's compared with less than a fifth
of men a survey that's been conducted
for good money week claims 27% of female
workers haven't even discussed the
subject with their boss because they
feel awkward well joining us now
Charlene Fanny from good money week
Mornington Charlene good morning I would
imagine you're not shy about asking for
a pay rise in light of what you've just
found it's interesting isn't it women
feel more awkward about talking about
money in general but especially when it
comes to their employers why well I
think generations of discrimination and
bias and working in male-dominated
environments doesn't instill that much
confidence but a lot of the women that I
speak to you feel just feel kind of icky
talking about money but when we think
about the fact that women are much more
likely to be ethical and sustainable
when it comes to their spending savings
and investments I would urge women to
see it growing their income as another
way to do more good for people on the
planet it's interesting isn't it
women feel like the odds are perhaps
stacked against them before they even go
into the room to start this conversation
and the statistics back their art
because it's not just the asking for a
pay rise that is a problem for women
it's the response they get because it
appears but it's not as positive as it
is for men no it isn't as positive men
are much more likely when they ask for a
pay rise to get sort of between 6 and
25% of their salary as an increase
I think it's 27 percent of men would get
that much where it's about only 12% of
women get that much but you know I think
what women really need to do is to learn
those negotiation skills so they can go
in there and feel empowered and excited
so you asked for that pay rise and ask
for for what they thought what their
worth really and equal pay very much in
the headline it's not so long ago now
and it was meant to prompt a more open
and fair discussion about what men and
women are being paid is that happening
do you think
I don't think it's happening yet so the
transparency about pay gaps that's so
neat that's only existed for a year so
it might take a bit longer but we do
need to do more so women it can go out
there learn those negotiation skills ask
for those pay rises join support
networks or other women who are talking
about money and getting their fair share
good money week website has got some
information on that and also think about
lobbying your MP around penalizing those
companies that aren't paying fair it's
interesting because there are other
topics of conversation that women find
hard to have with their bosses it's not
just pay rises but it's all sort of
linked flexible working hours the gender
pay gap and shared parental leave all
topics that are very much being
championed right now in many workplaces
but still it seems it's a difficult
conversation to have I thought the
opposite was meant to be happening yeah
these are still kind of new kind of
ideas and things there's a lot of
culture change that really has to happen
before women can really feel comfortable
asking for these things for example you
know men do have the opportunity to take
parental leave but aren't as often as
women are taking and the maternity leave
so you know there is a lot of culture
change that has to happen still but
women can and are coming together to
empower themselves to find the
confidence and to find the skills to
have these conversations and ask for
these things you know women are worth it
at they're doing fantastic jobs and and
they should be valued and rewarded for
that